Speaker 1: Let's go back to discord and hear
from a few more people. First and foremost,
I want to go to Adrian from Wyoming one. I
don't know why Wyoming is so interesting to
me. I've never been it has such a small
population. I would like to visit Adrian
and see what it's all about, you know?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Pleasure. Pleasure
to speak with you. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Perfect. Yeah, I live in Laramie, so
my parents actually grew up in New York, but my
parents both teach at the University of Wyoming.
It's the only four year school in the state,
so it's kind of an anomaly when it comes to, like
all the other small towns, but it's beautiful.
You should actually only go drive through the
mountains and see it all. But that's not the focus
of my question. I was actually wondering a little
bit about a different part of the world. Sure. In
that. I know. So you were born in Argentina and
I was wondering, there's an emerging group within
the South American left, like leaders like
Petro. Castillo until he was ousted. AMLO
I can't remember. I don't know if Castro is part
of it in Central America, but I was wondering if
you were thinking what your thoughts are on this
new rise of leftist leaders like Lula and if it's
built to last or if it's potentially susceptible
to more right wing takeovers like we just saw in
Peru and what the left in South America would
need to do to ensure that it's got more staying
power as it's a relatively new phenomenon.
Speaker 1: Listen, I don't know if it has
staying power. I know that on this issue there's
some people in the audience who like to say,
Oh, I'm some right winger, and my family
was part of the Argentinean right wing,
and that's how we were able to get out. And
we were supporters of the dictatorship. And,
you know, none of that stuff is true. All of
my family has been on the left and many are
even further left than I am. And, you know,
I have no sort of like familial opposition to
left wingers in Latin America. The concern I've
had with some of the Latin American so-called
left wing leaders of the last 20 years is that
often it's the exact same sort of playbook. It's
the populist rhetoric. And they do some good
things for the poor, but they rape and pillage
many of the resources of the countries. In some
cases, they abscond with obscene amounts of cash.
There's not always freedom of the press. There's
not always freedom of the courts we've seen in
Venezuela and elsewhere. So I don't take any kind
of like big picture, this is good or this is bad.
I'm on the left, right. So like as I've said
before, between Bolsonaro and Lula, if those are
my choices, I'm picking Lula. I also have concerns
about Lula, and I outlined them in the video I
did about him. And I have to say it a thousand
times, I still choose him over Bolsonaro, but
I don't think Lula is God's gift to progressive
politics either, you know? So I think we just have
to wait and see and evaluate these individually.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. I just I hope that they're
like I hope that they're going to say, I
was just in Colombia and I was speaking
with a lot of my younger friends there
who say they they have hope, but they're
and they're but they're a little worried because
the divide here is relatively stark, like as in
in the U.S. between my younger and older
generations as to the image of the ideal
society going forward. So, yeah, I was just
curious about your take and I appreciate the call.
Thank you very much for your time.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you,
Adrian from Wyoming, Great to hear
from you very much. Appreciate it.